on va pas parler des gios 2030 mais des
Jos 2024 puisque il y a une audition de
Laurent nunz le préfet de police de
Paris hier aussi ouais Quentin vous
allez nous en parler parce que on a
appris par voie de presse qu'UR qu'
allait avoir des restrictions de
circulation durant cesg et notamment la
possible instauration de QR code
Benjamin oui alors ça pose de questions
hein ça pose d'abord une question
juridique c'est-à-dire que évidemment on
peut la limiter les liberté de
circulation en revanche on ne les limite
que de manière proportionnée nécessaire
et cetera là est-ce qu'il est vraiment
nécessaire et bien d'instaurer une forme
de passe pour entrer dans une ville avec
quipuser bah des habitants et cetera
donc là fondamentalement il va y avoir
une question de proportionnalité
annoncer comme ça de but en blanc c'est
malgré tout extrêmement problématique
même si c'est pour des questions de
sécurité même c'est pour des questions
de sécurité encore une fois il faut que
soit proportionné toute la ville ne sera
pas forcément concernée là objectivement
on s'avance beaucoup le deuxième élément
et bien c'est que ça donne le sentiment
d'une encore plus grande distance entre
d'un côté les français et de l'autre
l'événement c'estàdire que on a déjà un
objet qui aujourd'hui met à distance une
partie de l'opinion si on considère que
qui pluser vous allez être étranger dans
votre propre pays pour les Parisiens
étrangers dans votre propre ville et
qu'il va falloir montrer P de blanche et
bien forcément vous ne créez pas un
engouement populaire contre avec ces
jeux qui plus est dans une situation où
l'organisation pose question non mais
tout a été dit par B je vois pas ce que
je peux rajouter au-delà que ça pose en
effet à mon sens un vrai problème sur le
plan juridique c'est que ça traduit
aussi ça témoigne quand même d'une forme
d'impréparation dans l'organisation de
ces Goos dont on sait qu'ils vont être
organisés depuis au moins 8 ans me
semble-t-il donc qu'on nous annonce à
quelques mois de la tenue de cette
manifestation des euh restrictions de
circulation pour des gens qui à Paris
quand même travaillent il faut quand
même aussi le signaler euh les Parisiens
travaillent les gens qui sont en
Île-de-France travaillent je pense qu'en
effet le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'on n'est pas en train de rendre ces
Jeux Olympiques pour la population
francilienne et parisienne très
populaire c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et puis sur le fond je crois que
c'est finalement je veux dire des
mesures qui sont assez inacceptables
parce que finalement qui crée le trouble
à l'ordre public dans cette matière
c'est l'état c'est l'état du fait de
l'impréparation du dossier donc moi je
trouve que l'annonce de cette mesure je
suis assez pondéré assez nuancé en rle
en règle générale c'est l'annonce de
cette mesure est assez scandaleuse en
l'occurrence donc je pense que il serait
bon de trouver j'allais dire d'autres
moyens pour sécuriser les Jeux
Olympiques que de faire de la population
parisienne la variable d'ajustement des
impéricdes de l'État ce qu'on a compris
dans l'audition d'hier c'est qu'en fait
le préfet avait presque voulu lancer des
informations en amont de toutes les
concertations qui sont encore en cours
sur les zones précises sur aussi les les
les raisons pour lesquelles vous devriez
avoir un justificatif parce qu' il avait
peur il a expliqué en audition que les
cartes sortent dans la presse sans
explication il a préféré prendre les
devant avec cette interview et cette
double page dans le le Parisien c'est
une stratégie qu'il a explicité hier
face à la front du Parlement qui est
reproché de ne pas avoir été voilà mis
au courant en amont B enfin je parle sur
le contrôle d'Arnaud mais ça s'appelle
un recul masqué ça
souvent en fait c'était juste c'était
juste un ballon d'essai vraiment non
mais évidemment mais là je rejoins tout
à fait ce que disait Arnaud c'està dire
que on a quelque chose qui doit être
préparé normalement bien en amont on
apprend qu'il y a des réunions à
laquelle la mère de Paris visiblement
n'est pas présente on apprend
aujourd'hui que on lance comme ça des
ballons d'essai sur des QR codes et des
restrictions tout de même massives de
circulation dans la capitale c'est pas
très sérieux et ça donne une image ené
si vous demandez au parisiens
aujourd'hui comment ils apprécient ces
GI c'est quand même un événement mondial
qu'on n pas tous les 15 jour la question
c'est où pars-tu en vacances au mois de
juillet au mois d'août parce que on veut
pas être là ça montre je dirais le degré
de distance aujourd'hui vis-àvis cet
événement non mais c'est un cas d'école
parce que je ne crois pas que dans
l'histoire des Jeux Olympiques il y ait
une ville qui a accueilli les Jeux
Olympiques et qui est final mis en place
des restructions de circulation pour ses
habitants même à Pékin lors des Jeux je
sais plus en quelle année les Pékinois
pouvaient circuler assez librement dans
la ville donc ça serait quand même un
come que la France ne soit pas en mesure
d'assurer finalement à la fois
l'organisation des Jeux et une vie à peu
près normale je dis à peu près normal
parce que ça me paraît assez compliqué
au vu de ce que l'on sait de l'état
d'avancement du dossier pour les gens
qui habitent cette ville on va parler de
la loi immigration puisque depuis lundi
les députés se sont emparés de ce texte
il a été adopté le 14 novembre dernier
au Sénat rappelle et alors les députés
Quentin ils sont en train de réécrire la
version du Sénat oui c'est ça avec un
symbole fort qu'on a vu cette semaine le
retour de l'aide médicale d'État les
sénateur l'avait transformé en aide
médicale d'urgence avec un panier de
soins réduit donc au cas d'urgence les
députés ont donc supprimé cette
modification du Sénat en rétablissant
l'aide médicale d'État une première
modification importante symboliquement
même si la mesure avait été rajouté par
les sénateurs et n'était pas au cœur du
projet de loi alors la clé de vote du
texte c'est l'article 3 sur la
régularisation de méti en tention c'est
là que ça se complique voilà depuis la
présentation de ce projet de loi
immigration depuis plus d'un an
l'équilibre du texte fait débat ce texte
voulait à cheval entre intégration par
le travail et efficacité contre
l'immigration illégale mais en fait tous
les groupes politiques ont une
appréciation différente de cet équilibre
les les députés ont ainsi détricoté les
modifications actées au Sénat début
novembre mais sans pour autant réécrire
totalement la version initiale du
gouvernement pour Rael les sénateurs
avaient supprimé l'article 3 pour créer
un nouvel article avec des rég alisation
au cas par cas par les préfets et bien
les députés ont refusé cela cette
semaine ils ont modifié le texte en
commission le préfet ne sera plus le
seul décideur mais en revanche il pourra
s'opposer à la régularisation un exemple
a été donné en commission par Gérald
hermanin si le travailleur sans papier
dispose d'unier d'un casier judiciaire
sa demande pourra être refusée par le
préfet ce dispositif serait donc un
compromis entre la procédure
discrétionnaire voulue par le Sénat une
procédure automatique de régularisation
et cet équilibre ça convient pas à la
droite et non d'autant que d'autres
mesures ont été ajoutées euh par les
députés ou même ont été supprimés plutôt
en commission à l'Assemblée nationale
délit de séjour illégale côas migratoire
durcissement du groupement familial de
quoi énerver la droite les chefs de fil
LR au Sénat sont montés au créneau cette
semaine pour dénoncer un des tricotage
écoutez Bruno retaillot ils sont en
train de tout déconstruire mais pour
l'instant c'est la commission moi
j'attends le final mais on voit bien on
voit bien que il y a ce ce grand
détricotage voilà et s'il y a un
détricotage ce sera impossible pour nos
députés de voter ce texte là même chose
pour Gérard archer qui dit attendre de
voir ce qui va se passer en séance he
parce que là on est l'examen de la
Commission et a ensuite en séance
publique ce qui se rappelle et tout peut
à nouveau changer hein dans l'hémicycle
tellement aussi les rapports de force
sont compliqués dans cette Assemblée
nationale depuis qu'il y a une majorité
relative pour la pour Renaissance il y a
des tricotages Arnaud mais c'est pas
vraiment une surprise non c'est pas une
surprise alors on voit bien la prudence
quand même de Bruno retaillot et de
Gérard Larcher d'attendre finalement ce
qui va se passer en séance mais enfin
quand même ça donne ça donne la tonalité
me semble-t-il ce qui se passe en
commission des lois aujourd'hui euh
c'est toute la difficulté pour Gérald
daranin il est dans un exercice de
chirurgie fine mais qui me paraît à ce
stade assez compromis pour l'objectif
qu'il cherche à atteindre c'est-à-dire
un vote de sa loi sans être obligé de
passer par le l'article 49 alinéa 3 et à
ce stade contenu de ce que l'on voit se
profiler à la commission des lois bon on
a par exemple rétabli l'aide médicale
d'État que les sénateurs avaient
transformé en aide médical d'urgence je
ne vois pas comment le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée nationale en tout cas s'il
veut encore garder une crédibilité
d'opposant vis-à-vis d'une partie de son
électorat ne peut pas ne pas s'opposer à
ce texte même si j'ai vu que une
quinzaine ou 17 parlementaires avaient
signé une tribune mais ils avaient signé
une tribune quand même en disant que la
condition c'est que le texte le texte
tel qu'il avait vé il a été voté au
Sénat soit adopté sin tout à fait dans
les mêmes termes mais enfin de manière
pas trop éloignée la façon dont il était
sorti de la Haute Assemblée donc ça se
complique ça se complique voilà est-ce
que puisqu'on parle d' le problème aussi
c'est pas la division DLR il y a
plusieurs lignes chez les républicains
alors sur ce sujet il y a plusieurs
lignes et c'est plusieurs lignes en
réalité toutefois la j taf Arnaud se
retrouve sur le fait que ce qui est en
train de se passer en commission des
lois fera que pour aucun a priori ce
texte ne sera votable et ça pose un vrai
problème pour Gérard al il y a quand
même un petit espoir sur la séance
c'est-à-dire que les commissions sont
composées à la proportionnelle des
groupes le problème sur ce sujet c'est
que la proportionnelle des groupes ne
signifie pas vraiment la proportionnelle
des opinions notamment au sein de la
majorité avec une majorité qui est très
clivée sur ce sujet on sait que la
commission des lois le le groupe
Renaissance notamment à la commission
des lois est plus tendance à chouill je
dirais que une tendance qui serait une
tendance plus droitière et donc se
faisant en séance il peut se repasser
des choses on peut avoir éventuellement
un texte qui revient un peu du côté des
républicains néanmoins à ce stade si
jamais on considère que la la Commission
est un peu prédictive et bien en effet
je vois absolument pas comment il
pourrait y avoir une majorité sur ce
texte h 49 alignéat 3 ouais parce que
Quentin qu'on qu'on précise bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe si les député
vote un texte trop différent de suelite
du Sénat voilà c'est ce qu'on est en
train d'évoquer c'est ce qui est le plus
probable un désaccord avec le Sénat une
fois l'examen terminé même après la
séance et donc avec sans doute le
recours au 493 pour le gouvernement
c'est en tout cas même ce qu'a dit
Gérard Larcher cette semaine on écoute
le président du
Sénat le texte il peut être adopté en
utilisant le 493 si le gouvernement veut
forcer la main ou si le gouvernement
veut un texte édulcoré il ferait une
erreur de le faire je pense qu'il ferait
une erreur de ne pas dialoguer fortement
avec le Sénat et la majorité
sénateor en Gérard Larcher qui conseille
au gouvernement de s'aligner sur la
ligne de la droite pour qu'un accord
soit trouvé entre députés et sénateurs
cela se jouera bien sûr beaucoup en
commission mixte paritaire lorsque SEP
députés se sénateurs tâcheront
essayeront de trouver un accord sur le
texte ça se jouera en janvier à priori
pessimiste rien ne permet d'être
fondamentalement optimiste pour l'avenir
de ce texte sans passer par encore une
fois le 493 la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si il y a
une situation de blocage ce que feront
les républicains est-ce que les
républicains à l'Assemblée nationale
vont mettre leur menace à exécution
c'est-à-dire comme le demande un certain
nombre d'ailleurs monsieur marlex ou
même monsieur Pradier c'est-à-dire
déposer une motion de censure après le
dépôt d'une motion de censure dans le
contexte actuel par les républicains
c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même un
risque pour le gouvernement ça
manifestement mathématiquement bon après
il y a quand même une autre variable
dont il faudra par que la gauche veut
pas suivre oui alors on verra mais on
verra ce que fera la gauche parce que
aussi également bon il y a si vous
voulez ce texte je veux dire peut
agréger des tas de formes d'opposition
élite soit on le considère trop dur soit
on le considère trop mou mais ceux qui
le considèrent trop dur vont
éventuellement pouvoir s'associer malgré
tout à une motion de censure et ceux qui
le considèent trop mou peuvent déposer
une motion de censure donc si vous
voulez il y a une agrégation des
oppositions qui est potentiellement
possible il y a quand même un groupe
dont il faudra suivre me semble-t-il le
l'attitude c'est le groupe
je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer du
côté du groupe lot pour les pour
l'instant on ne les entend pas trop là
sur cette question est-ce que eux-mêm je
veux dire vterer une censure sur cette
question ça pour moi le le débat reste
ouvert ouais elle peut possiblement
passer la la censure c'est complexe
parce qu'en réalité votre motion de
censure elle est pas décontextualisée
c'est-à-dire que elle est défendue par
un groupe et ce groupe et bien la défend
pour un motif hein vous avez des une
présentation de la motion de censure
donc là si LR dépose une motion de
censure ce sera parce que le texte sera
considéré comme étant trop mou et donc
la gauche aura du mal à la voter oui et
si jamais il y a pas d'unité de la nuub
derrière la motion il y a pas de motion
de censure qui peut passer donc ce
faisant en effet actuellement les
risques pour le gouvernement sont
relativement limités ce qui peut
permettre entre guillemets à LR d'en
déposer une parce que jusqu'à présent on
considérait sous qu'inquena que le
moment où le gouvernement pouvait tomber
c'est lorsque la motion de censure
viendrait de LR et LR s'abstenait de le
faire parce qu'en réalité si elle
passait potentiellement il y avait des
solution derrière là ça pourrait
permettre en effet au groupe aler de
dire regardez on l'a fait et en même
temps ça ne passera pas parce queune
partie de la gauche ne la votera pas
mais est-ce que déjà ils pourront la
déposer parce que c'est pas si simple
que ça m c'est pas simple il vous faut
il vous faut 59 députés et donc
aujourd'hui air ne les a pas en tant que
tel néanmoins ils peuvent aller chercher
quelques lotes ils peuvent aller
chercher éventuellement quelques
nonincrit voir quelques députés de
gauche et cetera mais c'est pas donné
c'est pas facile c'est pas aisé non mais
toute la tout le problème ça sera la
rédaction de cette motion de censure et
qui nous dira finalement sur la volonté
ça nous dira quelque chose sur la
volonté de de de de de delr d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la logique d'opposition
soit il ré il rédige une motion de
censure qui est un compromis qui permet
à la gauche de s'y associer mais c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué parce que
finalement ils ont des positions quand
même idéologiques très différentes sur
cette question de la migratoire ou soit
il rédigent en effet une motion de
censure qui leur permet d'une certaine
façon de pouvoir afficher une posture
d'opposant tout en ne prenant aucun
risque quand à j'allais dire la la la
l'adoption de cette motion de censure ce
qui soulagera parfois peut-être un
certain nombre de leurs députés après
ils peuvent en rédiger une et ne pas
trouver les signatures mais en faire
publicité hein souvenez-vous par exemple
des frondeurs à l'époque on arrive à je
crois 56 signatures ce qui évite en
réalité de déposer la motion de censure
alors est-ce que c'était voulu ou pas
peut-être par certains mais ça permet de
marquer une rupture sans aller jusqu'au
bout de la rupture ça peut être une
stratégie du groupaler alors déjà on va
voir ce qui se passe en séance hein
parce que là c'est en commission encore
la semaine prochaine ça arrive en séance
le 11 décembre et déjà en commission
l'ambiance est un peu tendu Quentin
ouais il est même complètement délétaire
hier soir un incident a marqué à la fin
de la réunion de la commission lorsqu'un
député la France insoumise Hugo
bernalicis a demandé la suspension des
travaux de la commission parce queil y
avait en même temps une proposition de
loi LFI qui était examinée en séance et
il a fait cette demande de suspension de
façon très vigoureuse il sa'est même lev
pendant la commission refusant de sortir
regardez un extrait ça a été filmé par
des députés avec leur téléphone
[Musique]
portable HUG Beral qui dit alors refuser
de sortir qu'il faudra le faire
sortirit veut s de la salle sachaier le
président de la commission des lois a
annoncé avoir demandé des sanctions à
Bron PIV la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale ouais et cette ambiance plus
que tendu est-ce qu'elle peut se
reproduire en séance alors le
gouvernement a dit qu'il voulait prendre
le temps de dialoguer sur ce texte
est-ce que ça veut dire que l'examen
peut durer des semaines Benjamin ou
alors théoriquement en effet il peut y
avoir des effets de ralentissement après
vous savez d'un point de vue procédural
il y a tout ce qu'il faut pour
aujourd'hui accélérer les débat donc il
peut y avoir une capacité entre
guillemets de bordelllisation mais cette
capacité là malgré tout elle est
maîtrisée et cetera il faut quand même
relativiser je dirais le caractère
exceptionnel de tout ça en 47 par
exemple vous avez des députés
communistes qui s'enchaînent au banc de
l'Assemblée c'est pas une façon de
parler ils s'enchaîne vraiment donc vous
voyez c'est pas si nouveau ce type
d'action en ranche train de donner des
idées au
déput en revanche ce qui est peut-être
assez nouveau c'est l'absence de second
degré c'est-à-dire que avant vous avez
des manœuvres d'obstruction complètement
ubuesque he souvenez-vous des 134000
amendements sur la loi électricité en
2004 à ce moment-là vous avez des
moments vous avez pierre louche qui part
avec une torture dans l'assemblée c'est
pas nouveau en revanche il y a une forme
de second degré à la buvette on fait on
fait tomber la pression et on arrive à
Diler à discuter on sait comment est-ce
que ça va finir par un 49 Aline 3 et
cetera là j'ai l'impression que ce qui
est très nouveau c'est que de second
degré il n'y a point et que donc et bien
il y a des tensions qui ne sont pas mimé
qui ne sont pas imaginées qui sont
réelles qui sont profondes et qui
peuvent mener en effet à des épisodes
parlementaires assez triste oui je
partage totalement ce que dit encore une
fois Benjamin parce que c'est vrai qu'on
a par le passé des épisodes
parlementaires et 47 et 48 me paraît une
date tout à fait intéressante qui ont
montré queil y avait parfois des débats
qui étaient extrêmement violents je suis
pas sûr qu'ils étaient forcément au
second degré euh en 47 et 48 quand les
députés communistes traitent traité
Jules moque quand même grand résistant
de SS ou de nazi alors qu'il était
ministre de l'Intérieur je crois pas que
c'était du second degré de leur part
mais enfin peu importe en tout cas c'est
vrai qu'on a connu des périodes éruptive
sur le plan parlementaire sous la 3e
république sous la 4e République y
compris sous la 5e répuique donc ce sont
pas des événements nouveaux ce qui est
nouveau c'est grave quand même ce qui
non mais ce qui est nouveau
fondamentalement juste un point ce qui
est nouveau c'est le le le fait que
aujourd'hui si vous voulez c'est c'est
c'est visible immédiatement c'est
visible immédiatement c'est ça la
différence fondamentale donc ça crée un
effet d'hystérie qui se répand je veux
dire médiatiquement politiquement et qui
renforce l'hystérie ambiante je crois
que c'est ça la grande différence par
rapport au passé mais encore une fois
les parlements ont été largement
éruptifs dans l'histoire de France allez
on va faire un truc beaucoup plus dét
pour terminer cette émission c'est
vendredi c'est traditions c'est
patrimoinees Benjamin et qui dit
décembre dit marché de Noël oui Adrien
fin nous emmène dans l'un des plus
célèbres du pays celui de Strasbourg il
attire chaque année 2 millions de
visiteurs du monde entier et parmi les
produits forts le pain d'épic spécialité
qui se transmet de génération en
génération et qui a sa capitale la
commune de gviller ah
ouais en Alsace ce sont un peu les stars
des fêtes de fin d'année
en plus des millions de visiteurs une
foule de bonhommes de pain d'épic peuple
le marché de Noël et pour beaucoup de
touristes pas question de revenir les
mains VI ça fait partie de la culture un
peu de laazas de la laoren donc j'en
ramène pour mes parents et pour ma
famille on est Laurin à l'origine et que
notre fils habite à Mayotte et qu'on va
lui envoyer les Nunettes à Mayotte
d'épic au fig au gingembre au noisette à
l'orange les clients au long Baras du
choix chez cet exposant habitué du
marché de Noël cela fait plus de 100 ans
que la famille cuprix vend du pain
d'épices les petits Menel c'est un petit
bonhomme en pain
d'épic je pense fin d'année
prochaine oui ça va vous voulez un
sachet ça ça va aller très bien voilà
mademoiselle au revoir
merci nous depuis qu'on fait le marché
Noël c'est-à-dire plus d'une centaine
d'années on a toujours vendu du pain
d'épic la plupart de ces pains d'épices
artisanaux proviennent des ateliers de
lips dans le village de gviller au sud
de Strasbourg derrière ces murs qui
rappell le compte d' la première étape
de la confection commence au sous-sol
ici la pâteose durant 3 à 6 mois c'est
ce la
fermentationépre ça RAM
leateur des produits chimique la recette
n'a pas bougé depuis le 18e siècle les
ingrédients essentiels de la farine du
sucre et du miel 11 épic sont ajouté
dont quelquesunes ne sont connu que par
Michel abiger et ses deux
fils
toilé il y a de la cannelle du clou de
girof plus dans la de la cardam il y en
a encore quelques autres mais je me
rappelle plus à cette période jusqu'à
500 Manelle par jour son produit pour la
dernière étape il laisse parler sa
créativité si c'est pas une commande
particulière nous on fait plus ou moins
ce qu'on
veut comme là vous voyez c'est c'est
chaque fois notre décor entre deux pain
d'épic cet enfant du village se
transforme presque en guide
touristique
plusieurs quarts de touristes viennent
spécialement pour son atelier comme ses
allemands occasion pour eux de goûter
quelques
variété mais aussi de visiter la
collection de Michel abziger depuis 55
ans il l' enrichi d'objets typiques du
folklore alsacien et d'outils du passé
comme des découpoirs ou des planches en
bois al il y en a qui sont très vieill
la jeunentré une tout récemment elle
date 1613 dans ce même petit village on
peut trouver une seconde fabrique de
pain d'épices celle de Ford Wenger la
production se fait ici à plus grande
échelle 8 tonnes de pains d'épices et de
biscuits de Noël par jour soit 1600
tonnes chaque année la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires provient de l'export hors de
l'Alsace chaque jour nous envoyons à peu
près 150 à 160 palettes je dirais ça
fait 4 C semiremorques un petit peu
partout et bien finalement en France les
pin d'épices qui voyagent même jusqu'au
Japon et fort Wenger ne compte pas
arrêter son expansion si à Gard villire
on peut avoir jusqu'à 1000 personnes en
fait qui nous rendent visite en fait sur
ce site la première idée qu'on va avoir
là je dirais et bien c'est de construire
tout simplement un parking pour pouvoir
accueillir l'ensemble de nos visiteurs
l'entreprise explore même de nouveaux
horizons elle vient de reprendre une
chocolaterie d'un village à côté Quentin
on va continuer à parler marché de Noël
bien sûr comme tous les vendredis
[Musique]
c'est pour commencer d'abord on va par
la journée mondiale de lutte contre le S
c'est aujourd'hui voilà plusieurs titres
de la presse régionale reviennent sur
cette actualité ce matin comme dit
l'Union journal de reince 40 ans après
la prévention toujours nécessaire le
combat Contin continu en tour reine
titre également la Nouvelle République
il s'agit désormais de lutter contre
l'épidémie cachée en misant sur
certaines données encourageantes comme
le nombre de dépistages en hausse et un
nombre de personnes dépisté positiv qui
baisse le Courrier Picard rappelle que
depuis le 1er janvier dernier d'ailleurs
les moins de 26 6 ans peuvent se
procurer des préservatifs en pharmacie
c'est gratuit et beaucoup ne le savent
pas on le disait au début de club depuis
mercredi soir on sait que ce sont les
Alpes françaises qui sont les seuls en
liste pour obtenir l'organisation des
Jos de 2030 et alors la presse aussi
entre joie et inquiétude oui c'est ça à
l'image du Dauphiné Libéré qui fait la
liste des chantiers qui nous attendent
on na même pas eu le temps encore de se
féliciter de la nouvelle West France qui
titre sur une fierté et des critique
voyez déjà les Alpes ont déjà eu deux
des trois équipements qui posent le plus
problème à construire la piste de
bobsleake de La Plagne et le trempelin
de saut à Courchevel construit au début
des années 90 pour les gios d'Alberville
mais il manque l'anneau de ptinage de
vitesse reste aussi des questions sur
les transports avec parfois 300 à 400 km
entre certains sites des giio 2030 les
associations écolo s'inquièent également
du bilan carbone de cet événement record
de pluie en novembre dans les ardenes
beaucoup de précipitations qui ont fait
gonfler les cours d'eau comme la Meuse
que l'on voit à la Une de l'ardenis
Charleville mésière n'avait plus connu
autant précipitation en novembre depuis
2014 mais les parapluies vont laisser
place maintenant au moufle en décembre
avec d'ailleurs des températures
glaciales dès cette hiver on attend - 3
voire - 4 degrés dans la Marne ce
weekend on souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire au journal La Marseillaise
ils fêtent leur 90e anniversaire les
gouralistes de la rédaction qui pose en
Une de dans le titre de nombreuses
personnalités politiques syndicales de
la culture rendent hommage au titres
engagés envers les travailleurs et fier
de son héritage issu de la de la
Résistance ça y est c'est l'heure des
marché de Noël comme tous les vendredis
voilà comme chaque semaine effectivement
dans cette émission de mi-novembre à fin
décembre sur moi merci beaucoup les unes
effectivement de la presse régionale sur
les marchés de Noël ce passage obligé
dans l'Est de la France avec un zoom ce
matin sur les marchés de Noël de l'autre
côté de nos frontières il y en a de très
beau à voir dans au Luxembourg nous
apprend le républicain Laurin le journal
de mes voilà c'est un peu la spécialité
de Quentin les marchés de Noël vendredi
prochain marché qutin merci beaucoup
pour cette press merci Benjamin merci AR
AR la une de la revue politique et
parlementaire le savant le politique et
le peuple l'enjeu du siècle tout à fait
c'est à lire merci beaucoup à tous les
deux à la semaine prochaine merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi on vous souhaite un
excellent weekend et on se retrouve
lundi